[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
on tuesday 26th of april 2022 at the us
ramstein air base in germany an
important summit was held more than 40
allied countries met to pledge the
military support necessary for ukraine
to withstand the onslaught of the
russian bear in just the first two
months since the invasion began the
allies have delivered more than five
billion dollars in military aid to
ukraine
nobody is fooled by putin's pretext or
his phony claims on donbass russia's
invasion is indefensible and so are
russian atrocities nations of goodwill
from around the world stand united in
our resolve to support ukraine in its
fight against russia's imperial
aggression lloyd austin u.s secretary of
defense visualpolitik fans beyond
igniting solidarity with ukraine the
russian invasion has made one thing
clear you cannot trust tyrants least of
all from countries as hostile as russia
the idea is that if you're serious about
peace you have to prepare for war this
is a sentiment that is spreading
throughout virtually every allied
country in the world from germany to
japan to australia and that's exactly
what explains new stories like these
german defense investment will double
country's 2022 debt
how the ukraine war is changing japan
tokyo moves towards a more assertive
security strategy but it is precisely in
the former warsaw pact countries that
this idea is taking root the most
if we want to avoid the worst i.e war we
have to act according to that ancient
rule that says if you want peace prepare
for war jarroslaw kaczynski deputy prime
minister of poland and leader of pis
virtually all central and eastern
european countries have realized that
they have to start preparing for war and
as we say around here no sooner said
than done that's exactly what they are
doing and head and shoulders above them
all one country stands out that is
gradually becoming an influential
european power listen up
[Music]
a leading player
when the soviet union collapsed in the
early 1990s the newly independent
ukraine was one of the most economically
prosperous post-communist states
prosperous in terms of the soviet
context if you know what i mean because
the truth is that everything that
resulted from the former soviet union
was a mess even so ukraine's
price-adjusted gdp per capita was about
20 higher than that of poland and if
this margin had been maintained until
today and ukraine had managed to carry
out a political and economic transition
as effective as that of poland or the
czech republic the ukrainian economy
today would be almost two-thirds the
size of the russian economy of course as
you all well know the story was very
different
[Music]
ukraine's three decades of independence
have been characterized by economic
stagnation internal divisions and
institutional decay that made ukraine
the poorest country in all of europe the
crisis was such that the ukrainian
economy did not rise above its 1989
level until 2005. this set the scene for
the first russian invasion of crimea and
lately the invasion of the whole country
however over the last 10 years things
started to change in ukraine and in kiev
they found a key partner in this whole
process of course we are talking about
poland
[Music]
during the last decade poland has
perhaps been the country that has most
influenced ukraine's political economic
and even cultural development it has
been its strongest supporter within the
european union and nato it took in more
than 1.5 million ukrainian workers
before the invasion and gave this
country the model to be able to leap
into development
[Music]
we are talking about two countries with
very close ties to each other in fact
for centuries they were part of the
polish lithuanian commonwealth and more
recently they shared their rejection of
soviet occupation
there cannot be a free poland without a
free ukraine nor a free ukraine without
a free poland polish folk seeing well
now after the russian invasion of
ukraine poland has become one of the key
players in the political news and also
the country that is leading the european
preparation for war listen up
the new polish power
russia's invasion of ukraine has made
poland one of the key players in the
crisis the country that is leading along
with the united states and the united
kingdom in supporting ukraine delivering
military weaponry and hosting hundreds
and hundreds of thousands millions of
refugees in the first three weeks after
the russian invasion alone poland took
in more than two million refugees to
give you an idea practically overnight
it became fourth on the list for
countries with the most refugees in the
world behind only turkey colombia and
the united states
[Music]
[Applause]
since the beginning of the war the
polish government and society have
mobilized to put in place an
unprecedented system of housing
transportation food psychological
support and aid of all kinds the polish
government is even paying smaller
monthly allowances to families who have
arrived from ukraine to help get them by
refugees are allowed to seek work in the
country and the health and the education
system has also been opened wide to them
tens of thousands of ukrainian children
are already enrolled in polish schools
we are talking about a titanic effort
and that's not all poland has also
become the gateway to ukraine for
western arms and supplies and one of the
most relevant political players of the
moment
ukraine war turns poland into america's
indispensable ally in other words poland
has suddenly become one of the biggest
adversaries of vladimir putin's russia
it is also an example of the military
race ahead
because visual politic viewers poland is
in the process of doubling its armed
forces from about 110 000 troops to
around 250 000 while also aiming to
become one of the most modern armies in
europe it is an extraordinary and
historic moment the introduction of
poland into a completely new world of
cutting-edge technology modern weaponry
and defensive means andrei duda
president of poland because let's not
forget that poland has a direct border
with both russia through kaliningrad and
belarus
perhaps that is why poland is one of the
few european countries whose military
budget exceeds the 2 of gdp set as a
minimum target by nato still in october
2021 polish deputy prime minister
jarosuev kaczynski announced the
country's intention to further raise its
military effort to at least three
percent of gdp
thus in addition to more than doubling
the size of its armed forces the polish
government also wants to expand its
territorial defense forces a support
army composed of volunteer soldiers and
above all to modernize its military
arsenal by replacing combat systems
dating back to the soviet era who knows
how much of this equipment ends up or
rather is seeing its last days fighting
in ukraine what better time to clean up
don't you think for example the polish
army was still operating some 500 t-72
tanks when the russian offensive began
and in its air force we still find
aircraft such as mig-29s and su-22s
however everything indicates that this
situation will change very soon and not
only because of arms shipments to
ukraine in july 2021 for example the
polish government announced the purchase
of 250 u.s abram tanks to supplement the
250 leopard twos it currently has in its
inventory another example is its aging
air force over the last decade the
number of operational fighter jets in
poland fell from 128 to 98. to remedy
this situation in 2020 the government
announced a 4.6 billion deal for 32 f-35
aircraft to be delivered in 2024 that
same year it also required a patriot
type anti-aircraft battery system for
4.8 billion dollars more recently in may
2021 it acquired 24 bayracktar tb2
turkish drones
all in all this is just a drop in the
ocean in order to modernize its armed
forces poland will have to make a major
budgetary effort over the next few years
however the government seems more than
willing and that is not just us talking
but rather the deputy prime minister and
leader of the ruling party yaroslav
kaczynski says so himself take a look
it is better to be safe and a little
more indebted jaroslaw kaczynski deputy
prime minister of poland but while
poland is perhaps the country that is
leading the way in this kind of war
preparation in eastern europe it is by
no means the only one listen up
[Music]
fight club
throughout central eastern europe they
are generally very clear they do not
trust moscow at all even being part of
nato is not seen as enough so one way or
another virtually all countries in this
region are starting to get their act
together to follow in poland's footsteps
a good example is the czech republic a
country where military spending has not
exactly been a priority in recent years
in 2022 for example only 1.35 percent of
gdp was budgeted to be spent on defence
which in any case was already a
significant jump from the 0.95 they
spent in 2015. be that as it may this is
something that is going to change
completely
the czech government has announced that
it intends to increase its military
budget by 60
by 2025. bulgaria romania and the baltic
republics are also announcing
considerable increases in their military
budgets
romania wants to increase defence
spending to 2.5 percent of gdp along the
same lines estonia latvia and lithuania
are going to increase their military
spending by well over two percent and
rest assured they will do so taking good
note of what happened in ukraine for
example i bet you anything that javelins
will pay a very prominent role
lithuania to spend over 1 billion
dollars on weapons from us germany of
course preparing for war is not
exclusively about military spending or
political relations there are many more
variables that we have to take into
account and one of them a very important
one is the infrastructure and while you
may be surprised this can be a weak
point
to win a war or pursue an effective
deterrent strategy you don't just need
an army you also need to be able to move
it that's why this is precisely why in
2021 the connecting europe facility was
agreed on a european union funding
vehicle that provides 1.7 billion
dollars to improve military mobility
however we are talking about a very
scarce budget at a time when the war has
made it clear that these kind of
provisions are needed so now we can say
that the russian invasion of ukraine is
making this issue a priority to prepare
roads trains bridges ports and airports
so that if necessary a lot of troops can
be moved quickly
[Music]
this is especially urgent in eastern
europe where many key pieces of
infrastructure such as bridges may not
be able to withstand the weight of
american british or german tanks
in europe one has had the view that if
we didn't need to spend on defence since
the 24th of february when russia
attacked ukraine that view has changed
completely george reichels analyst at
the center for european politics for
example one of the projects that could
be accelerated the most is rail baltic a
5.8 billion euro that's over 6 billion
us dollars standard gauge rail link
connecting estonia latvia and lithuania
with poland indispensable infrastructure
to ensure that large troop movements
could be carried out quickly in fact
there is even talk of extending this
line from estonia to finland by means of
a tunnel under the sea well we can now
expect this and other infrastructure
projects to pick up much more speed so
you see infrastructure is another
important way to prepare for war and
enhance europe's deterrent strategy
visualpolitik fans history keeps telling
us that a military victory does not
always mean a geopolitical victory
sometimes war only means defeat no
matter what happens on the battlefield
the u.s experience in afghanistan and
iraq makes this clear as does moscow's
own experience with the invasion of
hungary in 1956 the invasion of
czechoslovakia in 1968 or the imposition
of martial law in poland itself in 1981
in all of these cases triumph on the
battlefields did not amount to a victory
on the contrary we could say that they
were small triumphs of a country that
was already losing the cold war and that
was unable to unite and win the loyalty
of even its warsaw pact allies
in fact in all of these cases the
military intervention irretrievably
distance hungarian czech and polish
citizens much further from russia
regardless of what happens on the
battlefields of ukraine where russia is
already paying a huge price in economic
military and human terms the outcome of
the war is going to be exactly the
opposite of what moscow intended the
distance distrust and hostility of
ukrainians toward russia will last for
years if not decades
nato will emerge stronger more cohesive
better prepared and with the
incorporation of new countries from all
this hardship we will talk about this
soon here on visualpolitik if putin
wanted less nato united against russia
he's achieved the opposite and russia is
also going to have a border with much
more heavily armed and fortified
neighbors for years russia has been
trying to intimidate its former warsaw
pact allies now it's only emboldened
them but they will soon be in a position
to look russia itself in the eye and to
top it all off it is turning poland into
a continental power
[Music]
whichever way you look at it russia has
lost this war of course we already knew
that if we were to hand out an award for
the most absurd harebrained and
counterproductive political idea of the
last decade it would be hard to find a
better candidate than putin with his
heinous invasion of ukraine but at this
point it's your turn how do you view the
plans of the eastern european countries
do you think poland will eventually
establish itself as a full-fledged
european power should the rest of europe
follow suit leave us your comments below
and now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to visualpolitik if you
haven't already done so all the best
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you